[Music]
leo is with us in houston texas hey leo
what's up
hey mr anthony thanks for taking my call
i appreciate it and i also appreciate
everything you do i think you all are
great thank you sir how can we help
all right uh long story short i'm a
nurse in the healthcare field um
i saved a little bit of money here so i
have about you know 75 000
saved in my account
the thing is uh i've got about 60 000
left from student loans
and you know i'm like you you know i
think about paying it off real quick i
want to put a lump down just to you know
take care of the phone as much as i can
but i know it sounds kind of
uh
sounds kind of like
kind of straightforward or question but
with the new administration uh coming in
do i have to wait until they make an
announcement of like
whether or not they're going to
relieve some of the student loans
because they started to do it with some
of the people in public service
so i was just kind of kind of wondering
what your thoughts on that because i'm
just sort of sitting here and
you know kind of trying to play the
calculation game but you know
just wondering what y'all's advice on
that is cool well i'm glad you picked
nursing it's a great field to go into
very well done
and 60 000 in debt what's your income
it's about 80 000. good for you how old
are you
i'm a little bit older uh in my i'm i'm
40 so i got a late start uh but you know
that's okay so
well but here's the thing let's go back
on a couple of elements of your question
number one the biden administration has
not done any student loan forgiveness at
all that was not already on the books
they've not initiated a single thing
uh they've been in office for 10 months
11 months
almost 12 months okay and um
and so they've not done anything yet now
they've all talked a lot but welcome to
washington dc
um now and here's the second thing now
you can do whatever you wanna do dude i
mean you do whatever you wanna do but
what you're asking is you're asking ken
and i
so i'm 61 years old
and i've yet to receive a blessing
from washington dc
either party okay
neither neither president reagan bush
clinton
carter
these are all while i was an adult
okay obama
who am i leaving out w trump second bush
trump bush and bush
i've yet to get a check from any of
these people
you know you know where you know where i
built all of the wealth that we've built
is i took control of my own life and i
decided i was going to control my house
not wait on the white house
yes sir and so that's it's just a
philosophy of life i think those people
suck all of them
and i'm not waiting on any of them i
think they're all a tick on the butt of
america yeah and they're parasites and i
don't think i'm going to wait on any of
them for me to have a high quality life
yeah while you're waiting on that wait
for pigs to fly i mean it's the same
exact scenario think about how much
further along you're going to be in your
life if you cut that check today
today yeah i mean i've got 15 left over
i have like three friends that are uh
politicians
uh at a four if you count some local
people
but uh at a national level and uh and
and i and they're friends of mine and i
i appreciate who they are
but uh i ain't waiting on any of them
to fix my
life leo
because you're gonna have a long
wait
if you wait on someone in the white
house to fix your life your life is
gonna suck
so no don't wait on biden to fix your
life don't wait on trump to get
reelected to fix your life don't wait on
whoever you want to throw in the pie
here of disgust but don't do it yeah and
let me let me take this on practically
in 30 seconds folks let me just give you
the other side of the story that's a
campaign promise you might hear it from
the other side of the aisle so dave and
i aren't picking on biting don't get
your i'm picking on all of you
but listen to this that's a campaign
promise it is not good government
business all right for them to pay these
off
they make too much money off of this
there's state dollars invested in this
this is one of the most
i mean slimy intricate situation and
they're not going to ever do it there's
too many political reasons not to do it
don't buy the lie ever they're never
going to do it
i'm just going to lay it out i mean
they've done a lot of stuff i never
thought they would do but i'm not
sitting around waiting on them to fix my
life i know that pay it off dude fast as
you can oh by the way you borrowed it
too
this is the ramsay show